hello Fandango movie clips I'm Stephane
James and I played the legendary Jesse
Owens in the film race and this is
things to know before you run to see
race or race it's the incredible story
of the great Jesse Owens man who did
incredible things at a time in which a
lot of people didn't think it would be
possible for him to go over to Berlin
Germany in and essentially change the
world through his his love for running
and its love for sports it takes place
about two years before the Olympics and
transitions into the Olympics so we get
to see what it's like just before Jesse
you essentially does one of the biggest
things in our history as he owns his
daughters were so involved in the film
from really the beginning stages they
helped put in things that would help
make the story more personable know so
make sure we were telling the truth
about their father and about what that
time was like Jesse grew up in the
middle of the the Great Depression you
know so he wasn't living in a perfect
America he was obviously living in an
America that was still struggling with
race issues and even after doing what he
did in Berlin and changing the world he
still came back to America that wasn't
so perfect but it's just a testament to
the type of guy he was that he was able
to sort of find his way through those
kind of obstacles in and continue to
support himself in his family race is an
important film because it's a story of
inspiration I think that when people see
the film to see a guy who really didn't
have much all he had really was his love
for running you know his individual
greatness is what set him aside from
anyone else it didn't matter where he
came from or what he looked like he knew
he could he could accomplish great
things and I think if people can take
that away that it doesn't matter what I
look like or where I come from you know
a guy like Jesse Owens did it so I can
do it and people should feel inspired
and be able to take that away from the
film I'm Stephan James for Fandango
movie clips thanks for watching and be
sure to go see race February 19th
you